what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
today we have some
really really big spider-man no way home
news
specifically in regards to the trailer
and when we can
expect it and as it turns out it's not
that far away
sony has already begun to make some
moves and those moves are telling us to
get ready because the spider-man no way
home trailer isn't that far away
there are also some pretty big leaks
that i'm going to be talking about in
this video concerning mary jane
aunt may and gwen stacy and no i am not
talking about zendaya's mj
or marisa tomaze aunt may but of course
i'm talking about an
mj and an aunt may from other universes
we have some leaked photos to go over
and some other leaks as well
but of course first we'll start off by
talking about the spider-man no way home
trailer and when to expect it and a
reminder only 11 days left in my
stormbreaker giveaway all you have to do
to enter
subscribe to my channel and subscribe to
cosmic culture link in the description
down below so sony has now begun to
advertise spider-man no way home a
little bit more on their social media
platforms specifically the sony pictures
in germany the official sony pictures
germany youtube account has now changed
their background banner to a banner of
spider-man no way home which means they
are now promoting the film
they also changed their background on
their official twitter account
it now has the same banner that their
youtube channel has a spider-man no way
home banner
this means that they're getting ready
for a lot of promotional material to
start to roll out for spider-man no way
home which means the trailer is coming
soon
and it is about that time spider-man no
way home is
going to come out on december 17th of
this year 2021.
that means we're about six months away
almost from the official release
which means that the trailer should be
coming in about a month or two
now there is a lot of speculation going
around right now that they could perhaps
release the trailer on tom
holland's birthday which is june 1st
now this speculation is most likely due
to the fact that marvel studios released
the shanxi
and the legend of the tin rings trailer
on sima liu
the star of the film changchi his
birthday and yes
that is possible it is possible for them
to do that but if they release it
on june 1st which is only about 12 days
away
that's seven months before the actual
release date of spider-man no way home
well six and a half which is about when
they start to release teaser trailers
for movies so that is a possibility
however i don't think marvel and sony
are going to be getting into the habit
of
releasing trailers for new movies on
their star's birthdays
so i don't really want to get into the
habit of expecting that however
tom holland is kind of a jokester right
now and kind of
marvel and sony are too remember how tom
holland jacob babylon and zendaya all
teased us with
different title reveals at first then
not to mention
later on that night tom holland went on
the jimmy fallon show and
literally played a game called spoilers
with him it was a game where they
revealed spoilers about movies and they
still didn't drop the title however they
did the very next day
so the trailer could come on his
birthday or they could tease us in
another way
but if they do that that definitely
means that the trailer is right around
the corner regardless of what happens i
do believe that this trailer is going to
be coming in june or july
that's just the time frame that marvel
studios usually goes by and in this case
sony release a teaser trailer about six
months before the actual film comes out
then about a month and a half two months
later release an official
full length trailer where we learn more
about the plot and then in true marvel
fashion they're going to give us
probably about
20 different tv spots for spider-man
knowing home including some special
clips that show actual scenes from the
movie
now a lot of people have been asking me
if we're going to see
any sort of evidence for a spider-verse
film in the teaser trailer
and i don't think we're going to be
getting anything during the teaser
trailer i'm very hesitant to say that
we'll even get something in the official
trailer however i think it would be
a very very brilliant decision by sony
and marvel and their marketing teams to
show multiple spider-man in the official
trailer because that will drive people
to go
see the movie and it could make this
film the biggest movie of all time it
will definitely be
one of the biggest movies if the
spider-verse truly is a big part of the
film but if they show tom holland
andrew garfield and toby maguire all
together in spider-man suits or even not
in spider-man suits just
all standing together in the official
teaser trailer this movie is going to
just
blow all of the records out of the water
and luckily we don't have to wait that
much longer to see
hopefully the teaser trailer comes next
month if not it's definitely going to be
coming in july
sony's youtube channel for germany and
their twitter page for germany has made
the change
that is definitely in preparation for
promotions coming for the film and i bet
other countries pages are going to do
the same
pretty soon now as i mentioned we have
some other pretty big leaks today for no
way home
leaks that supposedly confirmed the
multiverse spider verse
is happening obviously this has not been
officially confirmed but
man there is a ton of evidence for this
if there's not a spider-verse film
i'm going to be really shocked so this
leak is actually very
interesting and it's coming from imdb
and i know what you're thinking and i
don't normally do
videos relating to imdb but just stay
with me for a second
and hear me out on imdb for spiderman no
way home
under the costume and wardrobe
department cast member list
it lists asukiya wang ling jacob
what is it list for her role for the
film personal
costumer for miss dunst now i'm not so
sure about y'all but i'm not really
aware of another misdunst
at least any worth noting in a
spider-man film that
is not kristin duntz there's definitely
not another
miss dunce that would need a costumer
now i know sometimes the castles for
imdb
aren't that reliable but this one isn't
just coming out insane
kirsten dunst is in the film as mj this
is something
very very subtle and there is more
evidence to back this up
on asukiya wong ling jacob's profile her
own personal profile
for her work it now lists this personal
costumer
miss dunst post production 2021
notice how it doesn't list the movie
that's rather odd because normally they
would just list the film that they were
working on
the only reason that they wouldn't list
the movie they were working on
is because they actually couldn't
because it's supposed to be
a secret which is what looks like is
happening here and it is worth noting
that
kirsten dunst is doing another film in
2021 which she is fully credited for
but the costume and wardrobe department
does not list
asakiya wangling jacob and it does list
other costumers so she would definitely
be on there if it was for that film
which means that it's most likely for
spider-man no way home and this does
seemingly confirm that kirsten dunst
is going to be returning as mary jane in
spider-man no way home
giving us further proof of the
spider-verse and further proof that toby
maguire is going to be returning as well
alfred molina is already going to be
returning the green goblin willem
dafoe's green goblin is supposedly going
to be the main villain
and now it looks like we have pretty
solid evidence that kirsten dunst is
going to be returning as well
so it would be just a total and complete
shock if tobey maguire's spider-man
didn't show up in the film
almost everybody else from his universe
is heck even throwing james franco i
don't care bring him back
everybody else is coming why not and
speaking of everybody else
one person who is apparently not going
to be coming back
is emma stone's gwen stacy according to
daniel richmond it doesn't seem like she
is going to be coming back and this is
due to her being pregnant
i know this is a character that a lot of
people would have liked to see
especially if she came back as some sort
of
different alternate reality version and
she was spider-gwen
however it doesn't seem like she's
coming back unfortunately but
somebody who does appear to be coming
back from that universe is
aunt may we were teased a long time ago
by atlanta filming who took a picture of
a person on set
wearing a coat over them so we couldn't
see who they were with atlanta filming
stating that this was somebody familiar
well we now have a better look at that
person and it appears to be sally field
aunt may from the amazing spider-man
universe and this was taken from the set
of
spider-man no way home so again if this
person really is her and it really does
look like it's hurt
that's just another thing pointing
towards the confirmation of the
spider-verse
i mean really if this is truly a
spider-verse film which i truly believe
it is they're doing a horrible job at
keeping it a secret
the worst kept secret in hollywood by
far but again it hasn't been confirmed
by marvel studios or
sony yet but it sure does seem like it's
all but confirmed however let me know
what you think in the comments
down below and don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell to stay
up to date on all things relating to
spider-man no way home
let me know how excited you are for the
trailer in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof